[Música]
la duma rusa ratificó los tratados de
anexión de doniesk lugans gerson
declaró que el uso de armas nucleares
solo Sería posible en caso de agresión
contra el estado ruso
el líder supremo de Irán el ayatolá
alija menay acusó a Estados Unidos y a
Israel de organizar las protestas por la
muerte de maxa Amin la joven que
falleció tras ser arrestada por la
policía de la moral iraní y cuya muerte
ha desatado un movimiento masivo contra
el régimen de Teherán
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva y Yair
bolsonaro se disputarán la presidencia
de Brasil el próximo 30 de octubre en la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones después
de haber quedado a apenas 5 puntos de
diferencia en la jornada de ayer
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición en Rusia porque
la duma la cámara de diputados ratificó
los tratados de anexión a la federación
rusa de las regiones de doniesc lugans
jerson y saporiya además de los tratados
fueron remitidos a la duma los proyectos
de ley constitucional para el ingreso de
estos territorios al Estado ruso Laurel
nos amplía
una ley aprobada por unanimidad los
diputados de la duma a la cámara baja
del parlamento ruso votaron todos a
favor de la anexión de las regiones de
iTunes
ya ocupadas en parte o en su casi
totalidad por músculo una ley que según
el jefe de la diplomacia rusa protegería
la cultura y las fronteras de su país
Quiero unirme a este ambiente festivo y
felicitar al representantes de estas
cuatro regiones de la federación rusa
no estamos reaccionando ante amenazas
imaginarias en países lejanos
estamos defendiendo nuestras fronteras
nuestra patria
nuestro pueblo de un verdadero genocidio
organizado por los Sucesores de los
acólitos nazis al servicio de Los Amos
de ultramar
el ministro de asuntos exteriores acusó
a Estados Unidos de haber según sus
palabras sometido a occidente y utilizar
a Ucrania como un instrumento de guerra
contra Moscú Y es que la mayoría de las
potencias o que sigue condenando la
anexión de estas cuatro regiones
[Música]
la fuerza de los referendos amañados
demuestra que Rusia se da cuenta de su
fragilidad y busca dar un barniz
democrático a sus ofensivas
no reconoceremos estos supuestos
referendos ni La anexión ilegal de
Vladimir Putin Esto no es más que una
provocación
Rusia inició la semana pasada el proceso
formal de anexión con el presidente
Vladimir Chiquis firmando la ley junto a
los líderes prorrusos de las cuatro
regiones pero ninguna está totalmente
bajo el control de sus fuerzas y Ucrania
ha ido avanzando en sus contraofensivas
en el sur y el este del país
cambiamos de información el líder
supremo de Irán el ayatolá alija menay
se pronunció por primera vez respecto a
la muerte de maxa aminb quien recordemos
falleció tras ser arrestada por la
policía de la moral iraní el ayatolá
declaró que se trató de un triste
incidente pero acusó a Estados Unidos y
a Israel de organizar las protestas
desatadas por la muerte de la joven que
desde hace más de dos semanas desde el
mismo día de su funeral tienen lugar
dentro y fuera de Irán
digo claramente que estos disturbios sin
la inseguridad han sido planeados por
Estados Unidos y el falso
régimensionista ellos planearon esto así
como sus agentes a sueldo con ayuda de
algunos iraníes traidores en el
extranjero ellos les ayudaron
y como les decíamos Mientras tanto en
Irán continúa el movimiento desatado por
la muerte de maxa aminy este lunes una
de las principales universidades
consideran suspendió las clases
presenciales después de que anoche fuera
el escenario de nuevas manifestaciones
manifestaciones y demás represión
policial las organizaciones de Derechos
Humanos afirman que más de 130 personas
han muerto desde el 17 de septiembre
cuando iniciaron las manifestaciones que
se han convertido en la mayor amenaza en
años para el régimen de Teherán
domingo enterana la policía
antidisturbios yerran y se dirige a la
Universidad shariff donde los
estudiantes protestan contra el gobierno
un manifestante ya detenido se encuentra
Atrapado en una moto entre dos agentes
uno de los cuales dispara a la cámara
con lo que parece ser una pistola de
pintura en otro video en las
proximidades de la universidad los
gritos de los manifestantes que huyen se
mezclan con el sonido de los disparos
[Aplausos]
las fuerzas de seguridad bloquean el
campo y rodean a los estudiantes
mientras intentan escapar de un
aparcamiento
al mismo día en la universidad de ISSFAM
en el centro de Irán otra manifestación
estudiantes Sierra niñez rompen una
puerta de entrada y huyen de los que
haces lacrimógenos
el presidente del parlamento instó el
domingo a la policía a tratar con dures
a los manifestantes advirtiendo que el
movimiento pretende ahora derrocar el
régimen teocrático de Irán y que está
afectando al estatus Internacional del
país
nuestro enemigo estaba dispuesto a
levantar Muchas de sus sanciones pero
esas protestas le han animado a aumentar
la presión sobre el pueblo iraní
Estados Unidos impuso sanciones a los
dirigentes de las agencias
gubernamentales y iraníes y a la famosa
policía de la moral del país las
protestas comenzaron después de que la
policía de la moral detuviera y
supuestamente golpeara a masa niní de 22
años por llevar el pañuelo en la cabeza
de forma incorrecta a mini murió el 16
de septiembre mientras estaba bajo su
custodia la ong y era Newman Rights
afirma que más de 90 personas han muerto
y más de 1.500 han sido detenidas
vamos ahora con información de Brasil a
pesar de quedar en segundo lugar por
detrás de Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva el
actual mandatario Yair bolsonaro salió
reforzado de las elecciones de ayer el
presidente no solo obtuvo un mejor
resultado del que le anticipaban las
encuestas sino que su partido liberal se
convirtió en la primera fuerza en el
legislativo Marta Moya con los detalles
mientras sus seguidores encomendaban a
Dios durante el recuento de votos Yair
bolsonaro obtuvo el domingo pese a su
segundo puesto en la primera vuelta una
importante Victoria Por una parte el
presidente brasileño obtuvo unos
resultados mejores de los que
pronosticaba las encuestas en su carrera
a la reelección pero su Victoria
legislativa fue otro de sus grandes
alivios en su cita con las urnas la
nación Sudamericana renovaba los 513
asientos de su cámara de diputados y un
tercio de los 81 escaños del senado el
partido liberal la formación del
ultraderechista logró hacerse con 99
asientos frente a los 80 escaños que
obtuvo la federación de partidos de
izquierda de lulada Silva en el senado
un paisaje semejante con los liberales
de ultraderecha marcando la Pauta con la
mayoría además bolsonaro logró que
figuras polémicas de su entorno lograran
escaños como el exministro de salud
Eduardo pasuelo criticado por su gestión
de la pandemia el ex titular de medio
ambiente Ricardo sales famoso por su
desmantelamiento de los de controla
ambiental o Sergio Moro el juez que
encarceló a Lula da Silva las
expectativas del presidente ya eran
altas al inicio de la jornada
expectativa de Victoria hoy teniendo en
cuenta los resultados en un momento
difícil para el país en general y en
estos 45 días de campaña ganamos en
prácticamente todos los estados de
Brasil y los recibimos muy bien pese a
todo las encuestas de cara al balotaje
siguen dando una mayoría al candidato
del partido de los trabajadores que se
comprometió a reforzar su campaña las
próximas semanas
es lo siguiente la lucha continúa hasta
la victoria final Ese es nuestro lema si
lo la gana Eso sí deberá enfrentarse a
un poderoso legislativo opositor que no
se lo pondrá nada fácil un congreso
mayoritariamente ultraconservador blanco
y masculino
las autoridades de Estados Unidos
confirmaron 87 muertes provocadas por el
huracán Ian y se prevé que el número de
víctimas mortales continúe en aumento a
medida que las fuerzas de rescate
accedan a las zonas que permanecen
incomunicadas mientras tanto en Florida
el gobernador rondes santis informó que
el estado ya cuenta con un 93% de
conexión eléctrica por otro lado está
previsto que el presidente Joe biden
visite las zonas afectadas en Florida el
próximo miércoles Rafael Pérez nos
cuenta más
aumenta la lista de los fallecidos por
el paso del huracán Ian por territorio
estadounidense las autoridades dieron a
conocer que las víctimas se contabilizan
en más de 80 el número puede aumentar a
medida que las aguas se retrocedan de
las zonas inundadas la mayoría de las
muertes se concentran en el estado de
Florida donde continúan las labores de
rescate en zonas incomunicadas
las operaciones de rescate están en
curso tenemos datos excelentes sobre las
operaciones que se han llevado a cabo
Obviamente si alguien llama al 911
acudirán Y responderán a eso si alguien
ha puesto algún tipo de mensaje que
están en algún lugar y necesitan ayuda
lo harán
según de santis El 93% del territorio ya
cuenta con energía eléctrica con el
avance de la inspección de las
autoridades locales salen a la luz
nuevas imágenes de la devastación los
testimonios son igual de impresionantes
la dureza de los vientos marcaron a este
residente En una isla de la costa oeste
de la Península
teníamos ventanas de vidrio ventanas
corredizas en el golfo que eran aptas
para soportar hasta 240 kilómetros por
hora así que me sentí bastante seguro al
estar tras ellas pero cuando el vidrio
explotó y comenzó a romperse en el
interior y cuando el segundo juego de
ventanas corredizas que era la segunda
Barrera interior cuando estallaron me di
cuenta que esto era un problema
el presidente Joe biden en la primera
damaiden visitarán Puerto Rico este
lunes y la Florida el miércoles en la
primera parada cientos de miles de
personas no contaban con electricidad
dos semanas después del paso de por esa
zona
y vamos a cerrar conciencia el ganador
del premio Nobel de medicina 2022 es
para el genetista sueco smante pavo por
sus descubrimientos sobre la evolución
humana para entender la importancia de
su contribución al conocimiento nos
acompaña nuestra especialista en ciencia
y salud más Romero sala bienvenida
Buenos días Gracias Rosa Buenos días mar
qué hallazgos le han merecido a Pablo
Este reconocimiento para que todo sea lo
podamos entender Pues digamos que su
gran aporte el principal es abrir la
puerta Tener información genética de un
ADN muy antiguo que se creía que el
tiempo ya habría dañado no hasta ahora
hasta sus aportes el único pues canal
que teníamos para ver hacia el pasado
eran las ropas los restos de huesos por
ejemplo la datación de carbono y es como
si de repente todos los científicos que
estudian la Prehistoria se les hubieran
desempañado las gafas y han tenido
acceso a toda esta cantidad de
información genética que no tenían antes
de hecho él fue el que se cueció el
primer ADN neandertal también
una nueva especie de homínidos los
denisovanos no en la en una cueva de
Siberia gracias a un pequeño hueso de un
dedo sabemos que por ejemplo los
neandertales se reprodujeron de forma
bastante consistente con los Homo
Sapiens sabemos que lo mismo ocurrió con
los denisovanos y que hoy en día
compartimos todavía ADN con estas dos
especies no así sean porcentajes bajos
también sus descubrimientos Pues nos
ayudan a entender las migraciones de los
Homo Sapiens y En definitiva no nos
acerca a responder preguntas como Cuál
es nuestra historia de dónde venimos Y
cómo nos diferenciamos hoy en día de
nuestros antepasados con una exactitud
que pues no teníamos hasta ahora y
técnicamente pero a nivel es que lo
podamos comprender cómo consiguió
acceder a información genética tan
antigua Claro Lo que sucede es que
muchas veces el ADN del núcleo de las
células está muy dañado por el paso del
tiempo y también puede llegar a
contaminarse Pues con bacterias otros
elementos externos entonces lo que él
hizo fue ir a buscar esta información
genética no en el núcleo del ADN sino en
el núcleo en el ADN mitocondrial de las
mitocondrias que como las centrales
energéticas digamos de las células y que
tienen parte de ADN no tiene una
información Tan completa porque por
ejemplo en este caso viene solo de la
línea materna pero es suficiente como
para ir reconstruyendo y además hay
muchas más mitocondrias hay mucha más
probabilidad entonces de encontrar
alguno que esté en buen estado entonces
gracias a la intervención de este ADN
mitocondrial de nuevas técnicas también
de secuenciación Y por supuesto de
rodearse también de un equipo pues muy
potente logró encontrar Esta técnica que
además sirve para secuenciar no sólo ADN
de homínido sino también de plantas de
animales extintos de patógenos antiguos
de todo lo que se nos pueda ocurrir y
esos hallazgos que implicaciones tienen
para entender nuestro día a día Claro
porque parece que estemos hablando de
cosas muy grandes no quienes somos de
dónde venimos que eso no es que no tenga
valor Pero sí tiene una aplicación en
nuestro día a día por ejemplo este
porcentaje de herencia que nos dejaron
los neandertales en nuestro ADN que se
calcula que es entre un 2% 3 1 4 no está
muy claro pero digamos menos del 5
sabemos que tienen que ver por ejemplo
con nuestra respuesta inmune en la
pandemia de Kobe 19 se explicaba por
ejemplo Qué personas en parte no podían
desarrollar covid grave gracias a si
tenían estas variantes genéticas
heredadas de los neandertales o no lo
mismo ocurre con la posibilidad de
desarrollar esquizofrenia artritis o
niveles de colesterol altos en Sangre y
de hecho también como curiosidad en los
países asiáticos todavía tienen una
herencia de los denisovanos por ejemplo
la población Pues tibetana todavía usa
para poder respirar y vivir bien a
grandes alturas entonces explican muchos
niveles Cómo vivimos hoy en día mar
Muchísimas gracias por esta explicación
por hacernos entender este Premio Nobel
de Medicina 2022 parasbante pavo y a
ustedes Muchísimas gracias por su
atención sigan con nosotros en Francia
34.com